hi guys long time no see PhD sorry got
something really cool for you though
this video look at it it's a big long
and a couple of weeks ago I got to go to
the University of Reading to give a talk
of my research and also to film a bunch
of experiments I've got a couple of
videos coming out from this trip in this
one I'm talking with dr. newly dr. gray
and Martin who has his PhD in
meteorology and we're launching a
weather balloon or radiosonde so this is
basically a bunch of scientific
instruments that you strap together you
put it on a balloon and you let it go
and then it radios the information back
to you it's called a radio song because
you know radio and then Saunders the
French first sensor I think and it's
actually a part of modern meteorology it
sounds kind of archaic and I'd bring
chrome up on this but it's actually
really really modern and a surprising
number of these you're not gonna believe
how many of these are launched every
single day so the motor the main part
this video is me again sit down with
somebody who really knows their stuff a
PhD in the field and we look at the data
that's coming from this thing in real
time as it goes through the atmosphere
and we're analyzing what's happening
when it enters clouds when it enters the
jet stream when it enters into the
stratosphere that kind of stuff and I
think it was really really cool to be
able to sit with an expert and you know
get the inside scoop on this stuff so I
filmed it all I really hope you find it
interesting
give it a shot and I'll be back a little
bit in the course of this video to
explain a few terms that we kind of
don't define because we're a bunch of
sort of meteorology nodes but over the
past Graeme and Simon to talk about what
we're doing in the experiment so today
we're gonna be launching a radiosonde on
a weather balloon and these radio songs
measure pressure temperature humidity
and we can also find out the wind speed
from these in the atmosphere so we're
not one of them but we're a little bit
of twist on it today we're gonna be
adding some special sensors and
pinpricks turbulence solar radiation and
something which gives information about
space weather now isn't this all a bit
old-fashioned why are we doing this
through satellite well one of the
problems is with satellites is create a
bit certain bits of the atmosphere with
satellites even at the top of clouds you
can look at the land surface but if
you're underneath the cloud how do you
know what the how do you know what the
temperature is going to be underneath
the
out jet-streams there clear air it's
just quite hard to find out what the
wind speeds doing so we need to launch
the radius on to find out all the other
bits that these satellites can't look at
this is modern meteorological science
yeah this is this is very modern and
thousands of these lots around the globe
each day and they form the backbone the
backbone of building up the picture
which the forecast is then used to
initialize their models so this is the
RS 92 radio song and we've got the on
this metal thing metal strip here we've
got the two midi sensors and the reason
we have two imaging sensors on the
radiosonde is as you get higher up into
the atmosphere it's actually a very cold
as it starts going quite hard to measure
humidity so one of the sensors is heated
up to di sit or the other one makes
measurements and then every 30 seconds
the sensor switch over and the other
ones ready so we get to maintain good
measurements of humidity this small thin
wire here is a capacitive temperature
sensor which provides the temperature
inside the radiosonde
there is a pressure sensor so we can
derive the radius and height and this
rather fashionable spiraling device is
it is the GPS and from the GPS position
we can work out the radius on speed what
isn't on a normal radiosonde
is this box here now here at University
of Reading we've developed a system
where we can add additional sensors to a
radios on so the first thing to look at
is there's a small photodiode in the top
here and we can use that to measure the
solar radiation as the bling goes up to
the atmosphere so on a day like today if
we do go through a low cloud we'll be
able to see it because the variability
and the solar radiation sensor will stop
inside we've got an accelerometer which
is very similar to that of which is in
most smartphones or Nintendo ease and
that commissions the turbulence as the
balloon flies up to the atmosphere if
the balloons perturbed by turbulence the
radiosonde will swing around underneath
the more the radiosonde swings the more
turbulence it's in so we can get some
interesting information about turbulence
majority this box is taken up with a
Geiger counter so
the sum is often going through different
solar cycles and it's cycles can affect
how many cosmic rays reach into the
atmosphere
it's at about a height of 12 to 14
kilometers which were able to see a peak
in cosmic rays which are detected by the
two Geiger Kreiger tubes which are in
here from that we can learn information
about how the Sun solar cycle is
affecting our atmosphere just like to
point out all the equipment the Graham
is talking about like everything in
total it cost like 500 quid to do on
these launches so thank you
meteorology department at reading so so
much for letting me do this it was
really really cool
I'm I hope you guys see that money sorry
for interrupting so I'm a party back to
Graham in the past he's filling up the
balloon late back not like the robber in
the past with me it's got a little
stretch of it more gifts in a normal
party balloon and presumably gets a lot
bigger the higher you go the planet
berth and that's what limits the
heightened depth
you can get fire because the balloon was
a big fan to speak but then you part
Nicholas much and there are other things
like you send up very slowly do you then
run out back to on the radios on is that
yet more electrical tape yeah well you
in you are
so we're just we're just running we just
launched the radiosonde so it's it's
been in flight for maybe just about a
minute now we're starting to get the
temperature profile in bread to come in
so it's about it's been about 18 degrees
at the surface and as we probably head
up into the first kilometer it's or
dropping to about 10 degrees C community
is about 65% the wind directions
Northwest and the wind speeds quite slow
is about three meters a second of the
minute which is very calm it's a great
great launch nothing nothing out of the
ordinary at the minute and it says were
going up the solar radiation you start
to get stronger so when you fly to the
atmosphere V we have what we call the
top of atmosphere so the radiation
Valley and we also have down below so
things like water vapor are very high
level ice clouds cause the value Lauren
so the Green Line here is pressure so we
started about just over a thousand head
Pascal's and that will decrease with an
exponential trend as we head up through
the through the atmosphere so so that's
I'm just going to retention see here now
is we see here the relative humidity is
gone to near 100% and there's an actual
dip in the temperature sensor so we can
actually learn a lot about this because
the is a little inversion at the cloud
edge so that's just ended o'clock so
it's just entered a cloud and come out
of a cloud at the same time so we can
see it was a very big jump here but
because there's a little inversion here
we can say well actually the radius one
has gone through the cloud and it's
actually got some moisture on the
moisture and instrument as a moisture is
evaporated off you get some latent
heating to actually causes the
temperature gauge to drop really quickly
for maybe like a few seconds as the
water evaporates off hi me again sorry
I'm not going to do this very often
trust me I just need you to point out
something here we're talking about
inversions what we mean here is
temperature inversions so normally in
the atmosphere the troposphere which is
the bit that we live in the temperature
decreases with altitude sometimes though
it increases with altitude and some
weird stuff can happen
interesting meteorology that increase in
altitude with temperature is called an
inversion so that's what we're talking
about here just to tear that one up but
from solar radiation point of view your
values are a lot higher than they were
when I started talking five or ten
minutes ago so you're going higher up in
the atmosphere lesser that's being
filtered out but yeah in fact so the
fact we've gone through a cloud as well
and we're just about to hit freezing
it's just idling increasing yeah that is
another temperature inversion yes this
is temperature version so I suspect
what's happening here is here we've got
the cloud and so it's not a perfect
thing so maybe wait until cloud maybe
dived out cloud went back into the cloud
because if we would have worked out
today they're a little bit cleaner see
so this is this kind of pretty random
structure to them but what we get here
is talking an inversion and I'd say
given given the height we're about to
get to it's about 16 1700 meters that's
probably the top of what we call the
boundary layer so between the so the
structure actually is such that we have
even the first two kilometers a boundary
layer and that's basically that their
part the atmosphere which reacts the
Earth's surface to get turbines from
flow over buildings you get heating of
the atmosphere due to convection and
this will happens the first two
kilometers and then you you reach a bit
and it's often marked with the
temperature inversion this is actually
quite a big temperature inversion it's
surprisingly big temperature inversion
will have this inversion and as data
comes in it should start heading off
like that so no two balloon launches at
the same
oh no no absolutely no so in part my PhD
project we did some launches down in
Aberystwyth in West Wales the main aim
was to fly turbulence sensors which is
what's one one of the sensors are flying
today then you found you do one launch
say midday so it's not really much going
on well this is a bit disappointing and
you went two hours later the turbulence
is expected at the region of the
atmosphere it feels has expanded okay so
the big mystery here
Reavers was going with humidity so read
that graph for me what what can you say
what I'm what I'm seeing here is we're
in the boundary layer here and we've got
some clouds atop the boundary layer so
given that about kilometer we can say
right this clouds at kilometer and would
come out the cloud and we've gone
through this inversion bit in the
temperature and how I'm reading that is
maybe these clouds was here today and
the top of the boundary layer and what's
happened here is maybe we're
encountering a little bit more cloud you
look outside of it you see it's kind of
quite fractal and quite it's verified
and as we enter this the atmosphere here
this is more of the background free
troposphere so this is just moisture
that's been trans transported in the
troposphere and the humidity is a very
variable thing so from now I can say
it's this bit of the atmosphere is
looking like a typical radius on descent
but if it gets very dry we may have to
think about you know other things like a
drop of water both happening one thing
we've learned about doing maybe 50 or 60
of these launches is never say never to
end I think you always never know what
you're going to find right so what we've
got here is the just a plot of the
radius one's trajectory so in the center
here is where we launched from the
atmospheric Observatory here in reading
and we've slowly started heading out so
the radius on this probe out six
kilometers away from here it's heading
southeast of us so it's we're just gonna
head south over over Guilford and that
[ __ ] is doing how long we've launched
for what that's how so we're in about 12
minutes but would you expect the to
suddenly shoot away well so you say
we're it sir but we're just approaching
500 hectopascals so I checked the
weather forecast yesterday and there
should be a light jet so you can see the
actual speeds picked up to about 70
meters a second which is about 30 miles
an hour so in the jet given the for
Carter say that my expect in 50 to 60
miles an hour so expect
see this value actually increase in the
next the next four five minutes and when
we moon Catholics jet stream you
probably can encounter a little bit of
turbulence which you should be up with a
couple the accelerometer that's what's
happening so soon were you anticipating
that it's because eventually the balloon
is gonna pop yeah where do you think
it's gonna come down so I reckon it'll
either come down in a serious question
how many of these do you launch I mean
are they starting to clutter up the
world's oceans so they not about a
thousand of these a day across the globe
and so the Met Office they launched the
DEF acknowledge to down Campbell in
Cornwall to in Scotland and they looked
to a day and then as various automated
song sites around the country which
which launched two two times a day in
four times a day if need be so the UK
probably launches and they space about
ten to twenty a day so one is not trance
here most men didn't see center stage
they just learn the farmers land and
they just say and if you find it in the
bin of course when I was showing you
earlier the tech the sensors are so
delicate if they've crashed out in a
field
they're probably it's not worth
preparing them again which is what I'm
not put a camera on it because I'm not
breaking my GoPro yeah sorry it
complicates it so as you see actually in
the in the talking the the wind speeds
now we're at 20 meters a second that's
about 40 miles an hour as they're
actually when we started talking we were
six kilometers an hour without line so
it's actually really start picking up a
bit speed now since we've reached the
mid troposphere and so so this is the
jet stream that this in the jet stream
so the most intense jet stream we've had
on record was about 223 miles an hour
and this radio is on that to me to
Belgium and then the radio transmitted
wasn't powerful enough to relay or
information so probably even further so
I went even further than that but that's
the the departmental record probably one
say here is maybe here we've encountered
me so if you look up there's kind of a
haze yeah and that could be maybe just
quite thin high layer ice cloud which
we've we've encountered there over there
we can see we've got these sounds like
an autoworker altocumulus these are very
high level clouds and in the background
if you see this may be a wave pattern in
there and that could be due to maybe a
little disturbance in the atmosphere
able to do with the jet stream that we
saw the rip the radius on launch
it's caused a reversible wave that
affect the speed of songs not about 35
meters to 70 miles an hour it's actually
going actually a little bit quicker than
thought it would so if we actually look
here on the channel for Hillary this
lumbers moving around quite a lot so we
now know that's intervals they were
actually detect in turbulence now so
it's this mean we're getting towards the
topic I mean also looking in the
pressure we're getting towards the top
of the troposphere now last time I'm
interrupt it's really sorry don't don't
mean to ruin the flow so here what we're
talking about is we're about to enter
into the layer of the atmosphere that I
research the stratosphere now for those
of you that haven't seen my other video
is just gonna give you a primer really
quick the atmosphere it's like Hogan is
like onions it's divided into layers so
you have the bottom layer which is to
chop a sphere that we live in and that's
from like sort of the surface to about
ten kilometers in height that it does
vary we're now in altitude depending
where you are on on the earth and then
between 10 kilometers and 50 kilometres
you've got the stratosphere which is as
I say where I do my research so in 50
kilometres - what about 80 you've got
the Mesa sphere but we're not talking
about that in this video now the
troposphere as I said earlier has that
thing where temperature decreases as you
get higher in the stratosphere to begin
with it actually stays kind of constant
temperature as you get higher and then
it actually increases as you get higher
onion those two layers
troposphere and stratosphere have really
different dynamics going on they look
look totally different and the boundary
between them which we talked about in
this next a little bit is called the
trop apause and we're here trying to
guess where the truck pause is going to
be I'll show myself out
again I often like ladies gets the
height of the the tropic always say I do
have any clear idea I guess I mean my
default guess is 10 to 30 kilometers
which is where 9 now yeah I'm gonna say
about I reckon that 11 today but I could
be wrong
yeah so it's minus 36 up there which is
pretty cold so so we're getting must be
getting towards the tropical yeah in
winter so in winter so it by the
tropical temperature drop for is is
about minus 50 minus 60 so I'm feeling
probably an 11 kilometer estoppel pause
go into quite a wide sweep at the
atmosphere the other indicator has been
the drop was is the humidity all dropped
and that's because you can't convict the
moisture into the stratosphere yeah and
it's so cold up there to ice and it
turned ice and so the actual drop a
pause provides a layer there's just a
change between buoyancy and so when you
see the big thunderstorms you get over
the US it all founds out an armful and
that's because it might get there but
okay so if you've got very strong for
actually cancer punch through and you
get a little pop it but that's one of
the few ways you can get moisture into
yet into the stratosphere so when will
we know we've hit the stratosphere will
get quite a sharp change in direction so
it will the temperature increases high
anymore or sometimes it's sometimes it
can just kind of slowly Bend round so
sometimes I refer to it's a lazy chopper
pause when it's cut it's a bit ill
defined mmm but yeah we're still in
turbulence by the looks of it so this is
quite interesting I didn't actually
think we encountered maybe this much
turbulence today yeah so I think
all-round it's been quite an interesting
a sense so far actually speaking of
turbulence this is presumably the same
kind of telling us that you feel in an
airplane yeah and this is a lot of
planes will be flying approximately this
hour above the time though stratosphere
anyway yeah so is there ever a danger
that or are you ever worried you're
gonna hit a plane so there's been no
cases of a radiosonde hitting
playing or there's been no cases on
airplane having to take evasive action
or having damage due to radiosonde
important women I think so the proper
abilities of a radiosonde actually
either hitting someone on the head when
it drops down on a parachute or climbing
airplane are less than that win the
lottery so if you if it did happen you
should have brought lottery to you
congratulations he probably happening
shot by lightning so such a rarity I
think the only one recorded case was a
radio song had been launched from one
place in America and it landed in the
field site of another radiosonde
launching station and the odds of that
it was ranked like the most unlikely
thing on earth yes I think I think you
might be hitting the the Trop opposed
it's just starting sir it's to King
crowned so but that looks like that was
just a really well defined yeah that's
nice and tidy and I'm thinking it
probably was around 11 to 12 kilometers
say missus yeah give me that we entry
different bit in the atmosphere now some
things we should be on the lookout for
especially the temperature data if we
see little waves in the temperature data
there's these are inertia gravity waves
which always present in the lower
stratosphere I think we might have an
optimistic and proclaiming that we get
the stratosphere oh I agree with that
because we've got moisture to manage to
say 9% so that is quite an interesting
aspect going on so so there's a little
temperature and there was a spot so
that's a temperature most of the bottom
of cloud so it could be a very good
sometimes you do get a growth thin layer
of cloud against the transfer but this
is do something so you might actually
find this is the tropicals here yeah so
if there is a cloud that's what this
could be an inversion of the top of it
and also the inversion that starts so
could that have been as you said before
like an anvil the top of the round all
kind of cloudy
not I wouldn't say terrible from the
thundercloud but you're just a very
performs stratiform clouds top but as
you can see we most definitely probably
heading into the stratosphere now that
the image is just dropping so that was
always the to 13 kilometers that 13
kilometers I'm fine so if you go down to
the tropics the the trauma caused when
it starts of 15 kilometers yeah and if
you think about you just got warm
tropical air it just takes up more space
here just boom Aires takes up a large
volume than anything there's also a
Coriolis effect isn't that the fact that
the Earth's bulging out yeah well we're
not gonna reach the stratopause oh no so
what temperature do you think will climb
back up to this balloon before you make
it about 27 to 30 kilometers at least
around that quite you just start to see
the temperature increase going on it's
all these things when you look at the
thing it takes great the temperature
will increase a bit but it's actually
quite a large distance an atmosphere to
go before it starts very large distance
it's like um the same temperature what's
the fancy word for that isotherm
isotherm yeah when it's at an isotherm
just poke google away I love that when I
said it I said I'm so we're expecting
this to be isothermal yes but as I was
saying there were you get gravity waves
and there'll be a way for a slight wave
form appear in it but it's hard a second
minute of it like when we were looking
at the inversion tap it's hard to say
because we need to wait for the but
looking at the the radius on that we
that's been very definitely this but
it's a very different stratosphere so
what what exciting things do have the 14
hour is this sort of the end of the
interesting meteorology so we're
actually still experiencing quite a bit
turbulence with a accelerometers on but
the the second part of this flights
coming to being our which is looking for
these energetic particles because we're
now about 100 hectopascals so there's
the eighth tenth of the density the
cosmic rays are entering the atmosphere
and they're not being stopped by just
just a density of the air and so the the
Geiger counters that reward will be now
doing their job working out there
how much cost agrees actually get him
through yeah into the lower atmosphere
and not being blocked by maybe the Sun
so the sun's a minimum at the minute so
the amount amount of solar flares were
expecting is less so the cosmic ray
count is probably going to be higher
because there's less interference from
the from the Sun so how much longer do
you expect to be able to continue for so
100 about 100 so this should go for
another 10 kilometres to go do they go
assuming when they've burst they don't
tend to go laterally too much so when
they burst they mean after they when
they burst they they drop for a rock for
about kilometer and children socially in
the heart atmosphere the air is not very
dense into you and so the parachute
takes a little while to deploy but then
they pretty much follow the then if you
follow the wind perfectly they will just
sit in the wind but that's so well
defined I mean that's so clearly
dropping you there there yeah that's
really nice - okay yeah so I think we've
got some so what's that punctuated the
so you know she comes away fair
potentially sorry last night yeah
hey guys this is the practice you know
right so we're going 12.5 so it's just
I'm going to over plot so this all Patti
just keep plotting this week so yeah a
little sin theta so we're notices
there's been a bit of jump in the
temperature profile but yeah because yes
so thin up there it takes a while for
the the parachute to stop deploying and
having an effect but thank you balloon
you've provided us with some valuable
science I label data which the useful
term people looking at the space weather
you rotate servlets and just in general
shock I'm not taking it up
Thank You balloon you did us proud thank
you also for making it this far for the
video because my god
I know this is longer than most the
stuff that I make you made it this far
well done that the actual launch was
like an hour and a half two hours long
so I try to cram this in and make it as
like short and snappy as possible but
yeah it has to be a certain length so if
you like this though please please do
like the video comment down below that
you enjoyed it because I'd love to do
more of this kind of thing we actually
look for stuff in a bit more detail than
otherwise get on YouTube there's also a
couple more videos coming off my trip to
reading so Graham I think in the next
one that's coming out talks about all
the different instruments they have that
ready to look at sort of different
variables an atmosphere because some of
them are really weird and one of them I
wasn't I have to look at because it
would have blown my face off seriously
so there's that to look forward to but
do please like and comment if you
enjoyed this because I like to meet more
thank you for watching thank you to
University of Reading very much for
letting me do this and and for putting
pick me up putting up with me and I'll
see you in the next couple of videos
thanks again for watching